[Music]
the Hydra of Mythology was a massive
monster if you cut off one of its heads
two more would grow back in its place it
its teeth had the power to raise
skeletons it lived in the lake of Lerner
in the argus we found our Hydra at a
shopping mall see hydras are micro
animals found in freshwater around the
world often attached the duckweed and
wood floating on unpolluted ponds and
streams and while James our enterprising
Master of microscopes does often collect
his various microbial samples from the
great outdoors in Poland where James
lives the palms and rivers are too cold
most of the year for hydras but he'd
heard the hydras are a problem for
aquarium owners thus a trip to the model
this is the first Hydra he found the
micro cosmos is a many-splendored thing
and sometimes what it uncovers is a
toxin tentacled potentially immortal
hunter hitching a ride on an aquatic
snail inside a shopping mall aquarium
the good news is it doesn't have any
teeth so I think we're safe from the
skeletons
Hydra belong to the phylum Cnidaria
which makes them a relative of jellyfish
and sea anemone their bodies are small
about 10 to 20 millimeters in length and
also quite simple composed of two
cellular layers around a central cavity
which acts sort of like the hydras
stomach at the end of this cavity the
hydras body gives way to tentacles which
surround the hydras mouth like our snail
bound friend from earlier hydras usually
secure themselves to hard surfaces
including stones and bits of plants
there the Hydra waits for food its
tentacles are stretching up to three
times the length of its body in search
for prey like crustaceans insects and
even small fish much of the hydras
hunting ability lies in those tentacles
which are armed with little projectiles
cellular capsules called the mat assists
here you can see some de Matt assists
that were discharged by a Hydra which
happened due to mechanical stimulation
of the new mat assists as the sample was
being prepared the cylindrical body of
the new mattis's is attached to a long
thread which can serve different
functions one type of new mat assist is
equipped with a thread that is designed
to wind around the Hydra spray while the
thread of another kind of new mat assist
has an opening at the tip which allows
it to puncture the surface of the hydras
prey to inject a neurotoxin when prey
brushes up against the hydras tentacles
the mat assists are discharged quickly
and by quickly I mean very fast
experience around five million four
hundred and ten thousand G's of force in
as little a time as seven hundred nano
seconds that incredible speed helps the
thread of the new mat assist act like a
harpoon and catch its prey when a Hydra
isn't feeding its mouth is sealed with
the rest of its body in a continuous
sheet of cells so to eat the Hydra
essentially has to tear a hole open in
its body to let the prey in which it
does by sending neuronal signals that
stretch the mouth apart until finally it
rips open even more remarkable hydras
can open their mouths wider than their
body which lets them eat prey that is
bigger than them inside the Hydra the
prey is broken down into particles that
are taken up by surrounding digestive
cells now Hydra let's just get this out
of the way don't have an anus so the
remaining undigested bits of food go out
the same way they came in through the
mouth you may have noticed that the
hydras we've shown are either brown or
green you may have guessed based on
occurrences of the color green in
previous episodes that it suggests
something about chloroplasts indeed
green Hydra which are their own distinct
group called chloro Hydra are occupied
by unicellular algae which take up
residence inside of vacuoles within the
hydras cells
performing photosynthesis and providing
sugars in exchange for other nutrients
and protection from the Hydra hydras
have fascinated biologists for centuries
thanks to their spectacular regeneration
abilities they can withstand all manner
of violence Kutta Hydra and - and you
will end up with two hydras cut it into
twenty pieces and he will have 20 hydras
turn the Hydra inside out and it will
recover scientists have even blended
hydras down to their cellular components
spun them in a centrifuge so they packed
together and watched as the cells sort
themselves back in to Hydra for the
organism this all boils down to a unique
ability to continuously renew their body
through stem cells which is why Hydra
are sometimes called the eternal embryo
this is not to say they cannot die if
food runs low or water quality becomes
poor or something eats them then yes the
Hydra too will succumb but scientists
studying Hydra over several years have
found no sign of aging in the organisms
which means that barring all of those
challenges we mentioned earlier hydras
may be immortal but as mortal beings
ourselves the possibility of hydras
immortality will likely remain just that
to us an unconfirmed likelihood the
simplicity of the hydras body belies the
complexity of its life from algal
symbionts to its periodically torn open
mouth to its endless renewal and
regeneration all this
from an organism we found in a shopping
mall aquarium thank you for coming on
this journey with us as we explore the
unseen world that surrounds us if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes James check out Jam and
germs on Instagram thank you so much to
all of our patrons on patreon for
helping make this show possible and
better every episode if you want to sign
up
check out patreon.com
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby